I'm trying to remember my first Oscar
experience trying to think go for it I'm
just gonna wing it
um there are a lot of Firsts involved in
coming to the Oscars my oscar first was
the first time I got tickets as a
nominee and I was sitting in row C and
not row triple Z I was fortunate enough
to get to introduce YouTube I got to be
there at a rehearsal like a couple days
early so it was very weird to be in the
room where
the Oscars are going to be and it's
going to be like all perfect and
glamorous and amazing but people are
walking around with cables it's my first
job out of college and one of my jobs
was to haul one of the large Oscar
statues down Broadway to the David
Letterman theater I waited tables at the
governor's Bowl it was something that
was really special to me to be picked to
be on the hair styling team for the
Oscars in the back just hearing that I
was nominated was the probably coolest
thing that that ever happened to me I
was there in my pajamas running around
the lounge room and I said daddy's
film's been nominated for an Oscar and
they didn't even look up from there just
they just carried on I walked on to set
and everyone broke out into Applause I
remember the feeling it was surreal
surreal quite a surreal experience very
surreal and you know on the scale from
one to ten I'm still counting the zeros
last year I think I was
disassociating a lot they were about to
call out the winner I got numb in my
hands
arms all the way up to my elbows it's a
very exciting day this is my 12th Oscar
experience and it's just as fun every
time to be here with so many celebrities
so many beautiful nice people is is
overwhelming it was completely
overwhelming overwhelming it's just
overwhelming I think that's the
absolutely the best word to describe it
is overwhelming this is the very highest
moment in my life
I enjoyed it more than my wedding
it just felt completely outside of the
realm of possibility and here I am Oscar
nominated